Wow jesus what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert back
to gen 4 when you sleep was the air horn really
necessary for comedy absolutely this is a
multi-year journey you're about to embark on
who's your best friend nikki spandex spandex is
your best friend being a hulk asks for balance
you have so much more to learn
yes so i'm clearly nailing it at all these things
if you want to go back to life as a lawyer
i i respect that he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans
are coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for them and
i want the she-hulk to be the face of jennifer
wallace namaste i have a serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my cousin bruce
yeah that's quite all right oh people
only care because i'm representing
emil blonsky i think they care cause
they're like hey that girl's green
jen do your thing god i really like this outfit
i'm not proud of this
miss walters we answered to a higher power
our universe is on the edge of a precipice
i am a lawyer we do things by the book the
book of the shanty no the book of american
uh laws whether you like it or not
you're now a superhero let's do this
you know that friend you had in high school
who was way cooler than you were attractive
got all the attention from everyone
hello i think i'm jealous is that what i'm feeling
Welcome back everyone this will be my full
she-hulk trailer video there's a bunch of
easter eggs here obviously we see daredevil
in the trailer probably one of the biggest
things there's a bunch of cameos in all
the episodes so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes they're
gonna start in a couple weeks like we don't have
to wait that long before we actually get episodes
there'll be nine total and each episode is
supposed to feature like a different big
character but obviously the big thing
in this trailer is them just teasing
hulk training she-hulk how to be a hulk basically
how to use her powers more effectively but the
funny thing they tease here is that she actually
picks it up way faster than he expected which is
why they have that funny moment where she breaks
the fourth wall like she hulk does in the comics
breaking the fourth wall is something that she
does in the comics a lot when bruce banner tells
her oh you can go back to being a lawyer in the
normal world if you want to like you don't have
to stay here in seclusion with me and continue to
train for a couple years before you try to go back
because the whole idea is that it took him years
before he could become professor hulk and learn
to co-exist with normal people without just
completely destroying everything in sight one
of the big differences with the she-hulk character
and they kind of show you this across the trailer
is that most the time she spends her time in
that professor hook like state the in-between
state where she has her intelligent mind she can
speak just fine but she also has the power of the
hulk so that's why you hear all the jokes about
her being an eight-foot tall green lawyer because
she spends most of her time looking like that they
are supposed to be a little bit weaker than when
they're in full hulk state like she does have her
own version of a full hulk state this is what she
looks like it's way more like the incredible
hulk look than the professor banner hulk look
but the tone that they're going with in this is
more like a half hour legal comedy kind of like
ally mcbeal which is a deep cut robert danny jr
easter egg because a lot of you will remember that
he was actually on alec mcbeal before he came into
the mcu as iron man the joke when he says this is
going to be a multi-year journey for you is also
meant to be a backdoor reference to her future in
the mcu with the avengers characters obviously
he's going to cross over with other avengers
characters in the future probably avengers 5 kang
dynasty in avengers 6 secret wars now confirmed
because of the marvel panel we basically got the
entire marvel phase 5 in marvel phase 6 schedule
now there are a bunch of mystery movies on the
marvel phase 6 schedule they'll probably fill
in some of those during d23 later this year but
they'll include like the x-men movie deadpool 3
the movies that we know about after fantastic four
but they just haven't confirmed release dates for
yet the big idea is that black panther wakanda
forever which i just did a trailer video for
i'll link that below in the description and at
the end of this that's going to be the official
end of marvel phase 4 and then the beginning
of marvel phase 5 will start next year with
ant-man 3 quantum mania they showed off a teaser
trailer for that with kang the conquer so we'll do
a separate video about it later this week but the
end of marvel phase five will be the thunderbolts
movie that's happening right after captain america
four new world order so they're probably gonna
set the thunderbolts during captain america four
and then marvel phase six is going to begin with
the fantastic four movie and end with avengers 6
secret wars so they're kind of doing the avengers
infinity war and avengers end game thing where
they split like one giant avengers movie into two
separate ones i'll do a separate video about all
that avengers 5 avengers 6 stuff because we could
talk all day about that we are going to be eating
good for the next several years including the new
daredevil series that they announced because
of the big daredevil cameo seen at the end of
the trailer probably like the other biggest
thing that people are talking about in this
i think the even bigger reveal is that they
confirmed that he's going to be wearing a version
of the yellow suit which is actually his original
suit in the comics like daredevil started out in
the yellow suit then he got the more traditional
looking full red suit that most people think of
when they think of daredevil it's not clear if
he's fighting she-hulk here in new york city
or if he's also come to california because the
she-hulk series mostly takes place in and around
the los angeles area that's where her law firm
is based but this is just the beginning of him
coming back as daredevil like he'll get multiple
different suits and then when he does the full-on
daredevil series there'll be 18 episodes of that
by the way 18 episodes of daredevil he's supposed
to have a version of the back in black suit when
hulk is training her in how to be she hulk how to
handle her powers we find out that she actually
reversed to jennifer walter's state in her sleep
i think the whole idea with the base that bruce
banner has here the special laboratory with all
the stark tech like this all iron man created
technology that he's using here it's probably just
something that he keeps on the dl when he needs to
get away from civilization because of the way he
exists as the hook like he's worried about hurting
other people they make a bunch of jokes about
ripping clothes apart when she hulks out spandex
is your best friend later presumably she'll get
her comic book uniform that might not be till the
end of the series though one of the other funniest
moments from this is when she full-on flips him
the bird after he pushes her off the cliff just
trying to push her over the edge so that she
learns how to handle her own emotional state
they have all these jokes about what goes on
inside her law firm like the whole idea that
people make fun of lawyers for being more blood
thirsty than vampires like lawyers are worse than
the villains in the marvel universe the way that
her boss basically tells her that she is forced to
defend emil blonsky abomination so if it wasn't
clear he's being prosecuted either for what he
did during the events of the incredible hulk or
something else that he wrecked recently and he's
been in prison for that and her law firm in los
angeles develops a superhero division where she's
forced to defend a bunch of these super villains
and superheroes of crimes that they were accused
of there was actually a promo that they released
for she hulk at comic-con where you call a phone
number this is the actual phone number here it's
a real phone number like you actually get a phone
message when you call it and it's meant to be
like an advertisement for her legal services like
are you an asgardian god who's been accused
of destroying property every time you open
up a bifrost she jokes about ultron saying that
have you been accused of creating a sentient ai
that goes on to wreck half of the planet call me
jennifer walters to represent you basically so
that's how they get to all the different cameo
scenes in different episodes like you see some
of them in the trailer like they're meant to be a
bunch of funny c and d list characters that a lot
of you probably never heard of but there will be a
couple big recognizable ones like abomination and
daredevil for instance it makes sense that she
would run into characters like daredevil who is
a really good lawyer as he said who also spends a
lot of his time defending superheroes as a lawyer
they did confirm that this character here is
frogman right out of the comics super deep cut
some of these characters i'm not so sure about
like i'm not sure who the character jumping
out the window is supposed to be there's an elf
character pretending to be a judge like it's kind
of like loki pretending to be odin changing
the enchantment so that he reveals himself
the funny joke here is that when she's walking
by in her law firm like all the other lawyers
walk out the door just to stare and gawk at her
like wow eight foot tall green lawyer if you look
in the background though zoom in hands in this
guy's office he has a bunch of comic book covers
then they have all these scenes with abomination
pretending to be good obviously paying off all the
wong easter eggs from the shangshi movie with them
fighting in the ring together because wong is like
the other big cameo during this i believe the
way they're playing it is that they were trying
to rehabilitate abomination wong was helping
out with that just because he's so powerful
he would be useful to them but i think they're
trying to set him up for the thunderbolts like
he's pretending if he's gone good but he's kind of
like john walker version of good like john walker
us agent is kind of a dirtbag but he's not an evil
character he just does a lot of really shady stuff
they directly reference the events of incredible
hulk i have a conflict of interest this person
tried to kill my cousin bruce banner and that
is accurate to the comics she is bruce banner's
cousin but the funny thing is she's referencing
the events of the edward norton version of the
incredible hulk the woman that crashes into the
courtroom here is a version of titania you see
her in a couple other parts of the trailer she's
a big she-hulk villain in the comics so they're
going to go toe-to-toe a couple times they set up
all the jokes with her tinder profile or whatever
her dating website app she's using with everybody
loving her kicking the crap out of people as
she-hulk using her powers like they have
all these jokes about people being super
thirsty for jennifer walters like everyone
would love the idea of death by snooze new
because that's basically what's going on during
the trailer footage like this dude is going to
have the time of his life while she just pounds
the hell out of him literally and metaphorically
when wong shows up and says they have a greater
responsibility to something in the universe almost
ended basically he's talking about incursions time
runs out the events of the doctor strange 2 movie
he also references the book of vashanti which
r.i.p has been destroyed now also i think the
clever reference here when he references the
greater purpose that they serve in the mcu this
greater power is also meant to be a sly wink at
kang the conqueror because literally avengers 5
is kang dynasty like its avengers vs kang in
now based on the loki season 2 teaser we know
currently there is a version of king the conqueror
who's ruling over this version of the timeline the
character with the magical looking weapons and
these other guys here might be from wrecking crew
which i believe are supposed to be villains during
the series they're like a small villain group you
see her hook out she ends up wrecking the hell out
of them probably but we'll probably get a couple
more trailers before the first episode drops but
it will be episode 1 on premiere day august 17th
so of course i'll do videos for all the episodes
just like i do for all the other disney plus
series if you think you know what some of these
other miners and d list characters are supposed to
be besides like frogman like the bat and some of
these other characters let me know in the comments
i'm still working my way through a bunch of other
comic-con trailer videos and there was a bunch of
other trailers during the marvel panel too i'll do
videos for everything make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of those
i'll try to get them out as quickly as possible
everyone click here for my new black
panther 2 wakanda forever trailer video
and click here for my brand new spider-man
freshman year trailer video at easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!